let's go back to jail OHS engagement
news it's no secret that she's been down
the wedding road before and she's
clearly taking a few wrong turns let's
take a look back at Jennifer's rocky
road good love at the end of the day
it's just Jennifer and Sean it's about
who you are and what that person sees in
you and to me he's just Sean you also
said that Ben was your first heartbreak
it was real it was my birth and of
heartbreak really yeah I was an adult we
were about to get married it didn't work
out and it was just a bad heartbreak any
lack of romanticism or passion in this
relationship people said about you
dating younger man I'm not one to really
follow rules or you know stay within a
box
JLo's x-files include a choreographer a
singer an actor a rapper and a backup
dancer but JLo's first marriage was to
OHANA noah back in 1997 comparing the
rings from all her engagements it's
clear J Lo's got a tight she definitely
likes the emerald-cut but how does a Raj
reported 15 carat $1,000,000 bling rank
Marc Anthony's cost about four million
and the ring she got from Ben was a very
rare pink diamond estimated at 2.5
million and as for how JLo feels about
her two most famous exes you're on a
raft yes you look in the ocean you see
Ben Affleck and you see
[Music]